so today we've got a few fun tasks
well this is shattered I've never
spray-painted anything before but I got
this pig
I think he's broken he doesn't broken
look at his little Nikes mom sorry short
this pig needs to be silver gold does
not match my theme second thing on the
to-do list I need to install a capture
card on my PC I recorded a ton of Call
of Duty games last night and for some
reason they all got messed up I use my
Mac which I normally do and I'm not sure
if it was because the capture card that
I was using was one of the external ones
I'm not sure I'm just gonna install it
in my PC and hope for the best
although thank you note endows they sent
me this cute little gift box with our
new game fashion forward it also
included my favorite color nail polish
Zelda pins super cute Tory Burch little
pouch which I put my polishing first
things first let's go get to the capture
card installation
I need a Phillips small screwdriver
today we also have some really good news
I need a gerbil Monta
Matros that i was waiting to be
delivered was delivered it looks great
come on God let's go that's my boy
looks nice we still haven't resolved the
issue of the carpet underneath but I
think I found a solution so thank you
I don't just spare you guys the trouble
of telling me everything that I'm doing
wrong with this installation because I
don't want to hear it
see
are you happy
are you only we caught your balls off
for a reason babe we cut those off part
of my son hey what's happening to you
why are you so rowdy today so most of
our tasks today we're complete there
weren't that many I played a lot of Call
of Duty today I recorded a few episodes
so if you're not subscribed to my gaming
channel dead dead dead
I might start posting videos there again
so go check it out I just in gaming
right now we're gonna go spray paint our
Pig kind of put this GoPro in here
because I don't want it to get a spray
paint on the actual GoPro I also have
some movers leave this big thing in
saran wrap here so guess what we're
gonna do with this nicely over top of my
GoPro look I think it's good enough I'm
not really that concerned about it I'm
slightly concerned Wow
oh my god the pig is definitely cracked
guys this is a problem many mistakes are
made
like I'll use this again GoPro looks
great great idea
see no oh man this okay
feels good doesn't it look good it looks
just like they did in gold but it's over
I didn't know what myself I sprayed or
is it okay what else do you see what
else do you see here have boots on oh my
god okay that's actually really funny
their bobbleheads Wyatt so we didn't
really find collab with Jonathan and
drew the Scott brothers and they sent us
a little present and this is by far the
coolest thing I've ever seen there drew
and Jonathan on a shelf and they're Bob
woods I worked really hard on those pigs
yesterday it took me a whole company to
do it and it's just right outside okay
um no I put down a plastic garbage bag
but then I ended up spraying myself and
it's all over my hands and you know it's
a real a real solid attempt yeah that
we're doing right now okay
today's a really exciting day Lizzie is
in town and seen her for a while so
we're getting lunch right now they all
just went to order and I'd wait for the
dog Francesca's also meeting us I'm
super excited because she got a new dog
pretty with Ava and she is so freaking
cute they got her from a rescue and I'll
let princess to tell you more about it
but the dog is adorable and she looks so
sweet and I can't wait for Maddie to
meet her the meeting is going to happen
unfortunately it's happening here at the
restaurant so things might get a little
crazy but the good news so it's not many
people here so should be able to hello
oh my goodness no I didn't even say hi
to you in my blog yet so high they just
place the most decadent grilled cheese
sandwich that I've ever seen in my
entire life in front of you fancy kind
of that it's not real it's huge this is
my dream honestly
it's beautiful we gotta come back on
Tuesdays half today so how that I don't
know anything she's not checked it was
like crunchy the tomato soup and like
half offline I was like that sounds like
an adult heaven oh so pretty
maybe
Eva honey hi I want to give you a petal
about two cameras oh the babies oh hi
Matthew
your wild to wild happy oh my gosh their
wild one well it looks like that's what
has been destroyed let's take a nice
little look at it
oh wow girl unification destroyed it may
I offer room yes they're really precious
ate when I went down steps before today
was her first day she 2000 hit all right
this house has turned into basically a
play area for dogs that's really all it
is that's all that's what we do thanks
for watching this random vlog of doing
random things spray-painting a pig
playing dogs
what a great time I just realize that in
end this video so I'm editing it right
now I just play ecology with Matt and
I'm extremely upset with my performance
so I'm currently trying to calm down but
I'm gonna finish editing upload this
video and hope you guys have a good day
see you tomorrow bye